At a construction site, an engineer samples cement from a truck pouring a slab.
Three concrete cylinders are made and sent to a lab for compressive strength testing 28 days later.
Each cylinder is 6 inches in diameter and 12 inches high.
When tested, the axial compressive failure load in pounds for the cylinders is 53,667, 52,166,
and 64,918 respectively. What is the average 28 day compressive strength of the cement in PSI?
Okay, so in this problem, we're being asked to find the compressive strength in PSI.
We can see that the axial compressive failure load of the cylinders is provided in pounds
and we are given the dimensions of each concrete cylinder in inches.
So the manual here, if you want to search for something to look at, you can use the term compressive or
FC if you're using the search command. And that can bring you to chapter 2, section 2.5.1,
material properties and testing. This is a section about compressive strength
if you need a refresher on it, but the section itself does not provide an equation to use.
Instead, the only thing it notes that I think is worth pointing out here is a strength test
shall be the average of the strengths of at least 2, 6 by 12 inch cylinders. We have been
provided with three cylinders. So we are looking at units of PSI and as mentioned, we've been given
the compressive load in pounds and the cylinder dimensions in inches. All we need to do is
calculate the compressive strength of each sample and then find the result. So let's get started.
The area equation is going to be needed so that we can calculate the area of our concrete cylinder.
So each cylinder is 6 inches in diameter and an axial compressive test
is applied to the y-axis in a cylinder. Therefore, we're going to be using the 6 inches and not
the 12 inches. So area in this case is going to be pi d squared over 4. In this case, that's going to
be pi times 6 inches squared over 4. And this is going to come out to about 28.26 inches squared.
Now all we have to do is divide each of the axial compressive failure loads by that number.
So 53, 6, 6, 7 pounds over 28.26 inches squared equals about 18, 99 pound over inches.
Geward also called PSI. Then the second cylinder is 52, 116 pounds over 28.26 inches squared.
That's going to come out to about 18, 45 pound per inch squared. And then finally, we have
64, 9, 1, 8 pound over 28.26 inches squared. And that's going to come out to about 22, 97
pound over inches squared. Now all we have to do is get the average of these values. So
18, 99 plus 18, 45 plus 2, 2, 9, 7 divided by 3 is going to give us 2013.67 pound over inches
squared, which is very close to our answer of C. And that's all it takes to solve this particular
problem.